maybe a little bit darker
oh good that's good so those of you that
knew jim gray knows that this was a an
endearing quote he meant this in the
best of all possible
terms astronomy's data is big
there's no privacy concerns per se and
unlike
satellite imaging or with medical data
if you make an incorrect statement about
it because you're trying out some new
algorithm no one dies and we don't go to
war unnecessarily
um jim uh was a computer scientist at
microsoft and an
alumni at berkeley and he saw
astronomy as a sandbox to develop new
formalisms of
fundamental computer science research in
some sense we're
trying to reach back uh the other way
and astronomers are
starting to play around with some of the
new concepts in computer science
and and view view all of that as our own
sandbox and we're trying to do something
novel with it
i want to thank the organizers and thank
all of the other speakers it's been an
absolutely amazing couple of days
in some sense as a way to end this
workshop
i wanted to try to make this talk
fundamentally about a conversation
between computer scientists and
astronomers or physical scientists in
general
our stack really ends with uh with
insights about the universe
um but it starts with the things that
that you all do
and i hope as you'll see throughout the
talk and especially towards the end
i hope there's something that astronomy
is bringing to
the kinds of thoughts that that that
you're working on every day
one of the uh sort of fairly well-known
astronomers
is this guy named galileo he was a
pretty opportunistic and and in some
sense he's i think uh
a pretty good example of the way that
astronomers look at tool kits
um that they themselves didn't
necessarily invent uh he knew about this
thing called the telescope which
most people have been pointing out at
the horizon looking for enemy ships he
said what if i just do that and and look
up
and uh the rest in some senses is um
is history but repurposing telescopes
that were invented for military purposes
to point towards that horizon is in some
sense what astronomers have been doing
ever
ever since then and obviously with those
new eyes came some amazing insights
some ways uh he was the was the guy that
really put the nail in the coffin of of
the sort of ptolemaic order of the
of the universe the planets were
supposed to be fixed spherical orbs
and they weren't supposed to have moons
um and that uh
picture that he made um about 400 years
ago
of the of this discovery of the moons
around jupiter
was obviously an amazing landmark
i also wanted to show this because this
is really our first glimpse of
so-called time domain astronomy time is
moving
in the axis going down and angular
position on the sky going the axis on
the right
and synoptic observations sort of taking
observations repeatedly over time
plays a very big role in the work that i
do
i also wanted to show this to you
because it emphasizes the crucial role
that that
humans have in data collection or at
least had in data collection
and not just data collection but data
analysis and inference
you could think of this piece of paper
as not just a log book but
but a but a database
what's so amazing is that this one man
with his toy and intellect really
changed the world
so what happens and it's not a lot of
data what happens when astronomers get
more data
well we just add more people to the loop
right
harvard college observatory in the late
1800s was dealing with a
sort of vast inflow of photographic data
that was coming from remote sensors in
this case
photographic plates from the southern
observatories
and there was a set of questions in the
time domain
around finding and understanding
variable stars
but there weren't the same types of
computers we have today
so these computers these people who are
pouring over actual data were in some
sense a prototype of crowdsourcing
or you could think of it another way
prototype of grid and parallel computing
it's also sort of a personnel innovation
in some sense it also sets the
the groundwork for modern day data
mining
viewed from a sort of modern lens this
is obviously fairly pejorative to call
these people and they were all women at
the time
uh computers um in a in a modern way
however when we look at it
we can also see great things in the fact
that they were close to data and they
made some very important contributions
as you'll hear about later at the time
they were really interested in
understanding the fundamentals of stars
what is it what are their masses what
are their radii what are their
temperatures
and in making measurements of binary
stars in particular
it was thought that one could in in
concert with other types of data
make some fundamental measurements of
stars of a whole different type
so this is fundamentally what they were
looking for is binary stars
we'll come back to that later on today
of course we have graduate students and
post-docs
who are actually using the types of
computers that we all know very well
and the the the concept behind what we
try to do in our group uh which is
called the berkeley center for time
domain informatics
is figure out ways to take people out of
the
the real-time loop as you'll see
throughout the talk there's a great need
as we get more and more data
to be able to automate the sort of tasks
that people
way back when and even just a few years
ago we're doing in a manual sense even
ones that seem fairly cognitive
these are ones that we're actually
trying to automate away
we're concerned with the dynamic
universe this notion that
everything in the universe changes uh if
you have enough sensitivity
and we can see those changes unfold
before us
it's kind of easy to think about
astronomers as portrait artists but we
like to think of ourselves as celestial
cinematographers
because for us time is a very important
axis
in understanding the physics of what's
happening how fast or by how much tells
us a great deal about
the underlying physical processes
so with that i wanted to show you a very
important probably the most important
three frame movie you've ever seen
i'm sure you've seen longer length
movies uh before
why is this important well first of all
this is a snapshot of the same place
and the sky taken about 45 minutes apart
between
these images taken on a sort of fairly
small old telescope
about 60 70 years old and why is this
so unbelievably important first of all
you can see the kinds of
raw data that astronomers are dealing
with there's some noise in here
there's this uh effect called fringing
from the detectors um there's an object
moving here can anyone find that object
yes you're all pointing right there
very good there it is um so this
is the discovery movie of this thing we
now call a dwarf
planet called eris uh it turned out to
be larger than pluto
and this happened 10 years ago for those
of you that have children that are upset
about pluto being demoted
from its planet status this is the movie
that essentially um did it
this was a massive data mining effort um
and it was done uh not entirely in
manual mode but obviously had a huge
impact upon our understanding of our own
place
in the solar system here's another two
frame movie actually just superimposed
on top of it of each other
from the hubble space telescope there's
a dot here a dot here
there was a very very bright star
through various different techniques
were occulted out so we could see
uh from the essentially behind the glare
of that star
this very very faint object which moved
from here to there
in two years it turns out from there to
there
is a keplerian orbit and this is now
believed to be
the first image of an extrasolar planet
by direct imaging and this is just
happening
essentially in our own lifetimes so
watching things move in space
is obviously having a transformative
effect upon our understanding
of of the universe the thing that i
spend most of my time on
is how things change in brightness or
change in color
everything as i said if you have enough
sensitivity appears to change
um stars even though they might seem
fairly quiescent
if you have the ability to collect
enough photons quickly enough with
enough signal noise
you will actually see it burble around
uh that's not what i work on either what
i what i spend a lot of my time on is
working on
more dramatic things where i'm not
looking for changes in one part
in a million to the light i'm looking in
at something that wasn't there and now
it's there and then it's going to go
away
and typically this means that something
catastrophic happened
stars die and they blow up so this is
the realm of supernovae gamma ray bursts
and potentially even new phenomena
one of the important themes that you'll
see throughout this talk is the notion
that
just because we can make measurements of
these changes
doesn't mean we actually understand
anything about it
and in particular even if we've made an
interesting discovery of something new
that's happened in the sky
the greatest insights in astronomy
happen
when we're able to do follow-up imaging
or follow-up spectroscopy
or look back at archives the important
thing about
all of this follow-up after discovery
which is in some sense where the real
fun comes along
is that it's expensive they're re
they're real resources involved in all
of this
there's people there's time there's
precious telescope time
and it just goes on and on and on
fundamentally uh which i think makes
this whole problem
quite interesting we could probably turn
all of these resources
and all of the limited resources into a
notion of
of a dollar term and when we what we
learned is that when we start
sort of um couching the problems that we
have in astronomy
in sort of raw terms like that the
metrics that we wind up applying to
decisions
actually become even easier uh to follow
so it's not just the objects uh in the
sky
that we know about that are that are
interesting and i should point out um
this is a
one of the terms that i'll introduce
here this is what we call
light curves so this is basically time
on the x-axis here
and this is brightness in crazy
astronomer terms where this is faint and
this is bright
and there are a bunch of different uh
basically behaviors of brightness as a
function of time
of these uh very important types of
exploding stars
these are the two most most common ones
type 1a supernovae are the exploding
stars that are used to measure the
very precise expansion rate of the
universe have a great importance for
cosmology
and type 2 ps are more ordinary stars
blowing up
these are the things that we know about
and we find all over the all over the
place although they're incredibly rare
on the sky people have gotten pretty
good at finding them
and then there's things that have been
hypothesized to exist the so-called pair
production supernovae which is
brighter and all these other kind of
exotic
events it does it doesn't matter what
these what these terms actually mean
the point is that i'm showing you things
that we know about
and things that we think we know about
and in sort of a donald rumsfelian
view of the universe um there are the
known knowns and you know we can go
after those pretty easily they're the
known unknowns
maybe you might say that the theoretical
work might um sort of guide us in the
types of pictures and
and the time scales that we'd be uh
applying our
observations to to find these things but
then of course by definition i can't
plot
for you the unknown unknowns so
one of the major difficulties in doing
needle in the haystack work discovery
in astronomy is making sure that you
keep your eyes open for all these
different classes
of of possibilities and make sure
that if you're going after one of these
events which by the way would be a major
result if we could actually find an
electromagnetic signature of two neutron
stars merging
we have to make sure we don't completely
exhaust our resources and throw
all everything we have at every single
possible event so we
need to be very careful about
it's of course preposterous to think
about scaling up
say 10 to the 6 jodi fosters to listen
for what it is that we think we may hear
in the sky
yes we may be able to hear subtleties
that might be hard to program
a machine to uncover by itself
but observing and listening to the
universe doesn't guarantee discovery and
discovery of course doesn't guarantee
insight
this is especially true today as we just
get more and more and more data and and
for for optical astronomers those of us
working
in the visible regime this is really the
the golden era
of of time domain astronomy and big data
time domain astronomy
this is a depiction of the large
synoptic survey telescope
which is now on track to come on sky in
about 2020
this will be surveying the sky every
couple of days essentially imaging every
available part of the sky
essentially to unprecedented depths and
the amount of data
and information we're getting just about
the changing parts of the sky is is
truly mind-blowing for us we're going to
get light curves of almost a billion
sources
which will be updated every three days
we're expecting to
discover about a million supernovae a
year
and it goes on and on pick your favorite
sort of time domain object
and lsst is going to find these things
in spades
20 terabytes a night is um more than
most astronomers at most wavelengths are
used to collecting
although there's some other wavelengths
where that's actually not that much but
in in the context of scaling up those
computers that you saw at the very
beginning
if you think about that as actually
happening today
with saying well i've got more data i'll
just hire more graduate students
this is obviously not going to work
anymore this is easily a a pedoscale
problem
and this is happening at a number of
different wavelengths lofar and ska
is an even higher data throughput
problem
and uh what's exciting i think is that
we know this is coming which is good so
we can start preparing for it
but there are a number of precursor
surveys that we're
we're starting to sort of cut our teeth
on and this is for me
my real sandbox and saying well we can
try out new ideas
of how to do this sort of automated
astrophysics um so that we're ready for
lsst the large an optic survey telescope
so for us the the big data challenge and
this question that we ask is
how do we do discovery follow-up which
remember i said has got
uh resource implications and um
inference when
when the data rates and the requisite
time scales
procure preclude excuse me human
involvement
um it's an interesting question right
because going back
into in retrospect and looking at a at a
database
and saying oh wow there was something
really interesting a year ago i sure
wish we had used all of our telescope
resources to do some real great science
with it
that's obviously doesn't cut it anymore
right
so what's exciting about the time domain
is it adds this extra
element of urgency i need to take action
on the things that are happening in the
sky
right now for me to maximize the return
and so i think i've mentioned this a
couple of times already
where uh we're trying to automate the
scientific workflow and sort of in a
cheeky way
i'm plotting the barrier to entry as a
function of intelligence required to do
this
so there's the observing stack there's
the finding stack the discovery stack
the classification follow-up scientific
inference writing papers
getting awards standing at podiums et
cetera
that's not on the plot and some of these
things we're starting to really uh
get get a good understanding of how to
do well um under
the types of conditions that we all
operate in i'll talk more about all that
later
so observing is uh getting to be fairly
routine
robotization cue scheduling can it's a
constrained satisfaction problem
finding that is actually identifying
those objects in the sky
that potentially could be new maybe
they're just noise who knows but
really getting down massive amounts of
data into say medium amounts of data
and then discovery and this is where
we're going to draw
from computer vision and image
recognition
and i make a distinction by the way
between discovery where we might say aha
this is something of interest
i don't know what it is yet but i
recognize that this is something that i
may be interested in i want to do more
work on
i make that distinction between
discovery and classification
for the following or at least drawing on
the following
story from history again goes back to
galileo in
all of his observations of um of jupiter
it turns out that neptune at the time
when he was making these observations
was pretty close uh to jupiter in the
sky and galileo made note of it
in his database in his notebook and he
said here's a fixed star
galileo is not credited with the
discovery of neptune even though we can
go back
and with essentially no doubt believe
that he actually recorded it he found
neptune he's not the
discoverer of it it took another 220
years or so
for the actual discoverer to find to
refine neptune
and realize that it was something
interesting i think that's remarkable i
mean he would have been a very famous
person if he had actually discovered
neptune
once you've said aha this is i've not
only found it i've not only said this is
something that i care about
now you want to ask well what is it what
is the source of this change on the sky
what's the physical origin of this
and this is where we're starting to
apply some machine learning techniques
and then you want to do follow-up et
cetera et cetera so let me just
talk a little bit about automating
observing
one of the the great uh uh leaps i say
for astronomy and optical astronomy in
particular
was when we went from photographic
plates to digital imaging in the form of
charge couple devices ccds because for
the
same size aperture telescope we could
collect essentially
light at 50 times higher quantum
efficiency which means that we were able
to basically build up a much better
signal noise image
much quicker it also has some great
properties like they're linear and so
so the the the data that you get out of
it tends to be more accurate
um but after we got sort of the
uh we went from photographic plates to
digital imaging
we also had to take humans out of the
loop of operating telescopes
um and so we've gone from human
operations to robotic telescopes my
colleague alex philippenko has been
operating uh the
so-called k telescope on mount hamilton
not so far from here
for about almost two decades now
and that's been incredibly important
because getting these people sitting
on top of a mountain night after night
taking data is a lot harder than just
getting a robot pre-programmed to do
things
so this is something that i did early in
my career
i actually roboticized an old telescope
that had been mothballed
and then i decided to go beyond just the
robotization of it
so that i could put in you know a whole
list of objects that i cared about
where i actually asked the telescope to
figure out what it thought was most
interesting
to observe at any moment given all the
constraints that were put in by all the
observers
that had gotten time on the telescope
so beyond robotization we started
creating what i guess we could deem
intelligent data collection agents and
this is me standing in front of my
telescope
i highly recommend people getting
pictures of themselves in a smug
pose in front of stuff that built and if
you haven't done that already that's
okay for those of you that code a lot
you can just print out code and
have somebody take a picture so you can
show it in talks like this
what it does is autonomously schedule
itself based on complex prioritizations
again that's a constrained satisfaction
problem that we worked on for a while
um does detailed weather sensing so it
senses when it's in danger
and will try to shield itself and close
itself up when there's a problem
and it will react to new things in the
sky without any people in the loop again
remember we're trying to take people out
of this loop because
the the idea here is then we can be more
efficient with the way that we do
science
and so if there's an event say from a
satellite it will be able to slew if it
if it believes that it's important to
look at that object in that place on the
sky before anybody even wakes up
it uh tweets where it is on the sky so
that other people can follow this up and
actually
try to sort of draft off the locations
of where the telescope is
and under the hood it's um some
interesting stuff that we worked on
demonizing all the different subsystems
and making this into a formal state
machine
so that we could wrap our heads around
all the different problems that that
wind up
cropping up when you're doing a software
slash hardware problem
and the results have been pretty great
uh we've been very excited about it this
is a movie up here
going from one minute to 30 minutes
after one of these gamma-ray bursts
exploded in the sky
essentially without warning a minute
after an event was recorded by a nasa
satellite
and it more or less beamed down a text
message to the ground
this telescope had slewed over and
started taking data
and what you see is a negative image
here where it's very bright at the very
beginning
and you see after about 30 minutes it's
completely lost into the noise
it wasn't just a burst of gamma rays it
was also a burst of
visible and infrared light and you can
see the uh the light curve here just
basically fading from very bright
your eye can see basically down to about
here this was incredibly bright
and then it was tens of thousands of
times fainter than what your eye can see
within just a half an hour
if we had had a grad student in the loop
then maybe they would have had to
have their cell phone go off and they
rub their eyes and they fumble for their
computer
and they forget their password and they
log in and all of a sudden we're way
down here
and we get to miss all the sort of juicy
science in there
we're not the only people who are trying
to push the envelope a bit on
robotic telescopes this is now becoming
a more and more
interconnected system um of uh instead
of
sort of well-connected graduate students
talking to each other
we're trying to figure out ways to have
telescopes talk to each other
and actually federate themselves to
actually do observing campaigns without
any people uh in the in the loop
and so what we see here is a an initial
network
of these telescopes which are starting
to talk to each other and we obviously
have different roles
for the notions of publishers and
subscribers i mean what's pretty neat is
that this sort of topology
uh of this network has been growing
organically and i think it probably
looks a lot like some of the
um early days of uh of the of the
internet
um and and for those that are interested
i also
i created a essentially the language
that telescopes use
to not act not actually just talk about
where they're going to look in the sky
but describe different events in the sky
and this has been uh tremendously
exciting and there's been some actual
great results that are coming out of
just
um this network i want to keep going
though
and talk about what happens um when
after we've now scheduled the telescope
to look at something we've now
gotten the data we then sort of automate
this sort of reduction process
but now how do we wind up doing
discovery
i've been involved in one of these
precursor programs
to the large synoptic survey telescope
called the palomar transient factory
and what you have here is the kinds of
things that uh for the first several
weeks of this project which started in
2009
we were having ourselves and not just
graduate students and postdocs but also
faculty looking at images and these are
little two little places on the sky
um what you see here is a new image it's
a little postage stamp around a new
place in the sky
and all that nebulosity by the way is uh
nearby is sort of from a nearby galaxy
and then here's uh this new image right
here of a different place in the sky
and what we have is a deeper reference
image of the sky
basically built up over a number of
nights before this night
and we more or less just do a
subtraction to look for something that's
new nature is not usually so kind as to
draw
green arrows and and cross hatches
around where there's actually a new
object
but i wanted to point your attention to
this object right up here it got this
name 11 kly
that's not all that important the
important thing to note here is that
this is a pretty easy find
for an automated algorithm that's
basically just passing over these images
it's just noise and then there's
something that's obviously not noise
but then down here you see something
which is a little bit fainter which by
the way to your eye it's pretty hard to
see
this is a new supernova that happened on
the outskirts of a galaxy
which is um uh quite far away uh
half the edge to half the edge of the
observable universe
and what you see are these red boxes
around here
where the subtractions were actually
imperfect it's a
basically a very hard problem to do a
subtraction in the presence of noise
because there's subtleties in how the
atmosphere winds up distorting the image
the telescope is not exactly in the same
state
as it is today as it was in the past
and so this is a really hard problem we
get about a thousand images a night from
this uh from this project and from that
we're able to to extract
including all these red boxes all the
possible candidates about 1.5 million of
those objects a night
of those about a thousand of them are
actually bona fide new
objects in the sky about 300 of them are
about variable stars and about 10 of
them are new
transients new things that weren't there
and are now essentially there
these are new things that are exploding
somewhere in the universe
and we want to now follow these things
up so we've been working
on trying to automate this process of
discovery
and one of the things you wind up really
realizing right away is that discovery
is imperfect whether something is new or
not especially when i'm getting close to
the
noise floor it's um you know there's you
don't really know
uh if it's actually a new object um you
might learn later on after it's gotten
brighter or fainter than it actually was
but if i want to take action on that
right now
um this is uh this is an important thing
to understand so
we started more or less taking those
images
and trying to do even further
dimensionality reduction
more or less creating of order about 50
different so-called features
that really describe each one of the
candidates that sort of
fits to the gaussian what's the signal
to noise what's the distance to the
nearest
object etc etc and what you can see in
some of these um
uh in some of these pictures right here
in the two different colors
are uh basically examples from our
training data of real candidates so
these are real astrophysical candidates
and bogus ones um i i didn't point out
before but going from
uh 1.5 million down to about a thousand
is a pretty massive needle in the
haystack problem so there's a huge
uh imbalance in in these two classes of
good versus bad or as we call it
uh real versus bogus and so we have all
of these different features
um and it's really just a two two-class
problem we're asking
is this candidate real or not right and
so we've
we've couched this in the way that um
people who do machine learning can
understand
and we we threw as many kind of
algorithms at this as we could and we
wound up finding
that some of them did much better than
others this is the so-called roc
curve receiver operator characteristic
curve of false positive
and uh and missed detection rate um it's
an important
uh place to to uh be able to understand
where you want to be on this
curve if i really didn't um
mind having uh you know more or less
missing all the interesting objects in
the sky
and i was really afraid of going after
and using resources on all my
false positives i might put myself right
over here
where i have a very low false positive
rate so that is calling things that are
actually bogus calling them real
um but i would miss a whole lot of
interesting stuff right if i put myself
here i'd miss half of the interesting
stuff
so that's a problem uh if i went all the
way down here
um you know and i basically didn't want
to miss anything well then i would
really start blowing up my
um my uh my false positive rate so you
have to decide if you're now
trying to build a framework around this
in terms of follow-up
of where do you want to be on this on
this curve
so what we wind up doing is
uh basically bootstrapping the survey so
that we started off with just a couple
of training examples
and then as the survey went on we went
up getting real sort of ground truth
about what actually was real and what
wasn't
and we went up finding um as you might
expect that as we added more data
uh to uh this this uh the the training
set
we're able to get better and better
classifiers here's where we were in sort
of the original paper that i wrote in
2011 and just by adding a larger
training set we went all the way down
here
um for me this kind of brings back one
of the well-known statements from peter
norvig who said that
more data beats clever algorithms but
better data beats more data
i have a little bit to say about that on
on the next slide
but it's very clear that more data
helped us tremendously
in getting a better classifier even just
using the same algorithms
but what's interesting is that um what
we wound up doing is
we started uh sort of flipping the
training data so we took a real object
and we said that we actually now believe
that it was
bogus we took a bogus object and we
flipped it around and said that it was
real and we kept re-running things as a
function
of of how much we messed around with uh
the uh the ground truth
and we wound up finding is that um uh
only a few
algorithms did very very well in the
presence of what's so
what's called label noise um and we got
up to about seven or
ten percent label noise um that is being
wrong in the training set
and still produce a very very good
classifier so that was pretty
interesting for us
now those that were paying attention to
that thousand number going down to 10
uh it turns out that most of the real
astrophysical objects in the sky
are actually asteroids asteroids are
very interesting to a large number of
people but they're not interesting to me
at all
so we needed to figure out a way to get
rid of all of those so we weren't
actually
uh uh wasting our resources on following
up known objects
so we built essentially a parallelized
version
of a of a resource that was being used
and is still out there
called the minor planet checker we just
did this in
basically a couple of months with one
graduate student it's now being
used worldwide but for us this was
really the last step to be able to say
aha
we have actually made a discovery and
moreover we can because we have training
data
we can go back and figure out what the
probability that we're wrong about that
discovery actually
is so we can ascribe probabilities to
that discovery
this has been a great project and in
fact it's already ended and now there's
a new incarnation
just starting up called the intermediate
palomar transient factory but one of the
things that we were very excited about
was
illustrated in this three panel image
here
on august 23rd in 2011
there was a nice image of this galaxy
there was no
again green arrow that nature was
telling us to look there on the 24th of
august
there was this little new object that
popped up and it didn't move so it
wasn't an asteroid
and then on the 25th it was getting
brighter and brighter and brighter
this turned out to be uh a discovery of
a supernova
where after we did a lot of analysis
happen just 11 hours after the explosion
it's the first time we've been within
24 hours or maybe even three or four
days
after the explosion of what turned out
to be an ordinary type 1a supernova
it's the nearest type 1a supernova in
three decades
and it was discovered by our machine
learning framework that essentially
promoted it to the top of the stack for
people to actually do more inspection on
and follow up and because we got on so
early
and because we're able to basically
throw as many resources
at it as we could and we recognize the
the importance of it
we were able to make some pretty
interesting and useful discoveries
i'll highlight two of them here and this
is a bit of a
a busy plot but i want you to just look
at this
sort of green area here and note that
these are all different regions of
exclusion
in effective temperature and average
density of the actual object that blew
up there's a lot of physics that goes
into making
this plot but fundamentally all these
different lines rely upon
the a single observation of a non-uh
non-detection
what turned out to be four hours after
the explosion that an
amateur astronomer had essentially taken
uh in spain
um the non-detection of that turned out
to be very very useful
for limiting the actual radius and the
properties of the thing that would
eventually wind up blowing up and what
we were able to do
is basically rule out all types of
normal
stars and only allow in this space right
here
um very dense stars compact objects
either a white dwarf or
a neutron star and people have been
talking about white dwarfs as the
objects that blow up for type 1a
supernovae and as you know
type 1a supernovae are incredibly
important for understanding of the
universe
as great probes of the acceleration of
the universe
and yet we haven't really known for sure
what it is that's blowing up
astronomers are pretty great at this
they'll say i don't really understand my
probe over there but it does its purpose
so that's good enough for me
here we're actually able to rule out all
all other sort of reasonable
possibilities for the first time type 1a
supernovae are also thought to be part
of a binary system
where the the larger star is
transferring mass onto the thing that
winds up blowing up
basically causing it to explode after it
reaches
an important limit and there's lots of
different possibilities of the
configuration
of that binary system what is the size
and what is the age of the
of the of the stoner star et cetera um
and we were also able to exclude in this
uh yellow region up here
we're able to exclude many of the um
sort of
well-described theories about what makes
type 1a supernovae
because there was pre-existing imaging
of this place on the sky with the hubble
space telescope
and a non-detection of objects there in
the place where a supernova was going to
explode
just six six years later turn out to be
incredibly important for ruling out all
but just a few models
so um i i'm trying to point this out to
show that
uh we by sort of putting machine
learning uh into practice
we were able to do this massive needle
and haystack problem um incredibly
quickly
and we're able to do this sort of um
very important science
that informs really all aspects of
astrophysics
uh just uh uh as as quickly as one could
hope for
but i still haven't told you what
happens after we do discovery
right after discovery you want to ask
that question uh
what is it and here again we're bringing
in
some machine learning concepts where
we're using machine learning as a
surrogate
um to ask that question what is the
nature and the origin
of the variability um that i see
and in this sense this is what we're um
i would call classification
on the problem is uh in the context of
variable stars um it is a it is a zoo
it is a variable zoo of variable stars
and if i gave you an object which is
changing in the sky
and asks you to tell me even if you're
an expert what it is on the sky
you might have a hard time putting it
into one of these broad classes and you
might have a very hard time until you
got more data
to put it into one of these subclasses
if you've got great data
you might be able to you might think
that you can just sort of do some
template matching
this is um four examples of variable
objects on the sky
uh that are varying on a variety of
different time scales
from three different large classes of
variable stars there's the so-called
eclipsing systems these are binary stars
there's pulsating stars that are
basically changing their radius as a
function of time
and cataclysmic variables these are
things that are undergoing sort of
catastrophic mass loss
or some type of eruptive explosion
here again are some light curves this is
a pretty uh nice
looking so called w uma class star
and it's changing on time scales of of
hours
here we've got a so-called beta liary
which is changing on
time scales of order um days here's a
again a type 1a supernova light curve
and here's a long period
so-called mira variable so if you had
great data
and you had great examples from all of
these different classes of variable
stars
the easiest thing would just be do
template matching right
the problem is even though we have these
broad classes this classification system
uh is really kind of an ad mixture of
phenomenology and physical and physical
thought and physical belief
some of these classes are called x-ray
because they emit
x-ray um in addition to optical light
and some of them are
are called eclipsing because we actually
have a physical belief that one star is
moving in front of another
um but we don't typically have perfect
templates of all the things that are
changing in the sky
and even type 1a supernovae which are
incredibly regular in their light curves
again which allows us to make these
great measurements
to large distances and measure the
expansion of the universe
they're all different in their own right
and when you get down to the subtlety of
it each type 1a supernova and every
other type of star is actually different
in its own way
it's sort of like uh tolstoy and anna
karenina i guess
every unhappy family is unhappy in their
own way um
so uh there's really a lot of
interesting problems that start coming
up
when you're looking at the the actual
type of data that astronomers get
we don't get to have those perfect light
curves and
uh one of the things we have is noisy
and irregularly sampled
uh data when we actually extract
information
out of the data that we've now reduced
from the raw data
down to the the nice images sometimes we
could get the answer vastly wrong
and underestimate the uncertainties in
um in our flux measurements
might call that spurious data and if
we're thinking about follow-up uh the
telltale signature of what it is that we
might want to be actually observing
might not have happened yet so you also
have to have some predictive modeling
of uh what might be happening in the sky
so um the machine learning approach to
all of this is to
basically take all of the data that we
can possibly get our hands on
and coerce it into a large dimensional
feature space
and then with training data hope that we
can build a classifier
now not just a zero one classifier but a
multi-class classifier
that would actually allow us to do this
well i mean what's
what's interesting and so we do this
with about a hundred different um
uh features on a very large um data set
of variable stars
all the things in blue are sort of time
domain related features
again doing this in the presence of
noise and irregularly sampled data
so some of this stuff is non-trivial but
then also context features
uh this notion of where did this thing
go off in the sky
i mean what's what's interesting is if
you came up to me afterwards and you
said you know josh um i saw this
interesting object in the sky last night
it it got brighter and it and
it went away i might ask you first you
know well was it in the ecliptic plane
uh you know where a lot of the asteroids
actually live and you'd say no
and i'd say well was it in the galactic
plain you know because then maybe it's
associated with a star and you could say
no
and then i'd say well but was it near a
galaxy say oh yeah and it was at the
center of the galaxy
and you would say no is on the outskirts
of the galaxy and i'd say was the galaxy
red or was it blue
and you'd say red i'd say oh that's a
type 1a supernova and i'd be right 99
of the time um so without telling me
anything about the time domain of just
the context
of where this thing occurs in the sky if
we're able to
basically go after and and all the
different databases of that place in the
sky
and extract all this information some of
it rich some of it in place of the sky
we've never even looked at
and build a classifier on that we can do
great things
and so we're able to build a pretty good
classifier over i think this is about 25
classes of variable stars
where you want to have this is the true
class and this is the predicted class
and this is a whole sort of
cross-validated
error matrix and what you see is that
you want to have all your power along
the diagonal here meaning that your
classifier is basically
always right but unfortunately it's not
what's really interesting for us though
is that when you draw boxes
around these larger classes and don't
get into all the different subclasses
what's pretty interesting is that a lot
of the off-diagonal power still lives
within these larger classes
and so what's pretty neat about this i
think is that even though we didn't
tell this uh machine learning classifier
anything about the physics
or anything about the actual uh
connection of all these different stars
with respect to each
other there's something about the fact
that they all kind of look the same
as why the classifier maybe got some of
this wrong so
the classifier in some ways is
discovering some of the
physical behavior and some of the
physical connections between these
larger classes
and we're getting down to about 15
percent um classification error which is
pretty good
but when we actually start using a
structured classifier
where we actually use the taxonomy of
this classification
tree as it as it exists as people
created we get down to sort of five
percent um gross misclassification rate
uh which is pretty good one of the
things that
has been touched upon throughout the
last three days which i found pretty
interesting
is this notion of how we can learn
on say one survey and i should say that
when we take data
uh with one survey we're doing it with a
certain set of filters we're doing it
with a certain cadence so we go back to
the same place in the sky
at some level of frequency we're doing
with a certain telescope et cetera et
cetera
every survey is different so now if i
handed you that classifier
and i gave you all of my codes and i
said go ahead now you've got your new
survey go ahead and classify
you would do a very terrible job with my
classifier
and that's because the way that you
observe the sky
actually winds up changing inherently um
the the underlying
feature distribution and this is
illustrated pretty well
um in uh james long's thesis he's
finishing up right now he's been doing a
phd uh
in in the group um and what do you have
here is a
basically a depiction of a three-class
problem where you have feature one
and feature two and you can build a
perfect classifier
uh uh basically a decision tree of if
you're on this side here then you belong
to the yellow triangles etc etc
but if i take that exact same classifier
from this
survey called the parkos and i apply it
to data
and now where we actually know the
answers for all these uh these
three different classes you see i've
produced a very lousy classifier and so
this question of how you use decision
boundaries and classifiers from one
survey and transfer that knowledge
um onto another survey that has
different characteristics
is a is a very interesting question and
what's pretty neat is of course if
you're observing with a different
telescope in a different part of the sky
you're going to have
different um reasons for doing so you're
generally going to be probing a
different population of stars
and so there may be whole places in the
space of uh of of
of this large dimensional feature space
that are not even populated by one
survey and are incredibly well populated
by another survey
that's that's illustrated here with a
plot of um
the period of of known periodic stars
and the amplitude of basically how much
they're changing as a function of
of time over the course of their period
these are very large amplitudes
changing by basically um orders of
basically an order of magnitude
all the way down to very very subtle
changes and what you see here
are data from two different surveys one
is a
survey called asus this is where we had
all the ground truth
and then you have this other survey that
we'd like to know the answers in
sorry this is where we didn't have the
ground truth we have all the ground
truth from the training data
and you see that down here we have no
examples we have no idea what classes of
objects
those things are and so what we've been
doing is building up a framework
for doing active learning to figure out
how we can imbue
experts into this problem to allow us to
identify and manually labor
label the testing set of data so that
when we
sort of use the finite amount of expert
resources
we'd be able to in future iterations do
a better better job
on the classifier that i took from
survey a and then applied to survey
b i won't go into the formalism uh
here of of of how we did this but i just
wanted to show
that with a few iterations if we have
our off-the-shelf error rate
on this essentially transfer learning
problem
very quickly with just a few iterations
of active learning
we're able to get to a very very nice
classification error that's
essentially acceptable for this problem
i'm sure all of you know this but
astronomers have a very hard time with
the
slide i'm about to show the
classification
statements that we make on this noisy
data is
surprisingly fuzzy i can't tell you it
definitely belongs to that class i can
only give you
probabilities that that object belongs
to that class
and what you really hope for is that i
do a great job in calibrating those
probabilities i can get something that
comes out of my classifier and say
there's a
20 chances of this type of supernova but
what you really want in the same way
that
sort of um whether people will say
there's a 50 chance of rain
you actually want it to rain 50 of the
time right if they're
i'm wrong in either direction you might
get uh angry with them for different
reasons
so the catalogs of transients and
variable stars that we're building up
are necessarily probabilistic and this
is incredibly subversive to astronomers
because they like to go to a paper
of known class of this type of star and
say
ah i'll observe that but those were all
basically populated by people and
experts over the last 100 years
and a lot of those things actually turn
out to be wrong that's another sort of
sociological question
but we have to learn as astronomers to
say goodbye to black and white catalogs
because these catalogs if we're getting
lots and lots of data have to be made
in this probabilistic way and so we
tried to
make it as easy for astronomers to to
digest this
how am i doing on time yeah
okay okay good and what we did is we
built a website that allows people to
basically probe through
um the probability distribution for any
one of these stars
and sort of search around for the
different types of objects that they
care about
um this is using the google fusion
tables under the hood if people are
interested
so i can go to this type of rlyry i can
actually click on one that i might
be interested in and
there's the probability vector of the
top 10 most important ones there's the
actual
light curves and you see how crappy that
data is and then we even made it social
just in case marissa meyer wants to
potentially buy us
you know maybe yahoo will buy this thing
i don't know um
but uh we've gotten a lot of traction
with this in the sense that astronomers
who care about these different
subclasses are actually pretty um
interested in and they're learning how
to actually use these uh
these catalogs we've been trying to go
beyond this and now actually do
our own science you know again just
because you make a catalog doesn't mean
that it's actually
um all that useful you actually you're
doing this not just for the
the exercise of cool i can do machine
learning and make probabilistic catalogs
you're doing it because you actually
want to do novel science
so building a catalog so that you can do
novel science i think is only justified
after the fact if you actually do that
and
what you really want to do is figure out
what kind of science do you want to do
do you want to do sort of demographic
science where you want your purity of
your sample to be very high
and there you might sort of really tamp
down and
and put yourself on on a part of the roc
curve where you have very few
false positives or do you want to work
in sort of the novelty discovery
to go after the rarities where maybe
only one out of 100 objects that you
actually spend telescope resources on
turn out to be actually all that
interesting
and so we were able to do this with one
of my other graduate students
adam miller where we wind up discovering
some very very bright stars that were
essentially misclassified for the last
five or six decades where the
probabilistic classifier said it was of
this type
so-called arcor borstar or dy per stars
and um with just uh a couple of uh
of spectra we're able to confirm these
very very weird objects
i don't think i'll go into the details
of how well we do
relative just sort of blind searches and
blind cuts
i want to just end with a couple of
statements not about looking at catalogs
of data that have already been taken
but about doing this classification on
the fly right i already talked about how
we do
discovery on the fly now we actually
want to say is this a supernova is this
a variable star
and one of the great places we got some
training data from was
this uh group called the galaxy zoo
where we presented to them
citizen scientists a bunch of images
just like the ones that i showed you at
the beginning of the talk
and asked them is this a supernova or
not and this is not a supernova and that
is a supernova
and the citizen sciences got very good
and they they wound up marking up
a few hundred of these images a night
and build up a huge
training set for us we then of course
went back
and we looked at those places on the sky
and applied uh our resources of
follow-up and we got some ground truth
and what's pretty amazing is that we
were able to build a classifier
using their training data and the
classifier outperformed the people
basically at any single false positive
rate so our roc curve
was if you you actually want it down
here as much as you can was actually
below
the the citizen scientists themselves um
so that was uh that was pretty exciting
and we're now sort of putting this into
practice
where we're not just doing discovery on
the fly now we're also being
now we're actually able to make sort of
classification statements
on the fly about what type of object it
is and we don't have a lot of data when
we just have one
uh one new data point um we have to more
or less rely on context
and so we have a sort of simplified
version of the taxonomy
what's pretty cool i think um is that we
now
have the robot that's doing this
classification log
into the system that everyone in this
group actually uses
and it actually will log in now and say
i think this is a transient and i think
this is a supernova um
and so you know then you see a whole
bunch of people who logged in and said
oh okay it's at this distance it's this
type of supernova after they got
more and more data but the robot now is
responsible for more discoveries and
more classifications
um than the people are uh in this
project
um what's exciting about this is this
actually turned out to be a fairly
interesting supernova
um it was a paper that appeared in
nature uh a few months ago
because we were able to again get great
data and be and
sort of maximize our resource usage
i've been thinking a lot about machine
learning
because we've been drawing from all the
great uh literature on machine learning
to do the kinds of science that i'm
interested in doing but i've been
thinking about
how that may be a bit of a misnomer that
notion of learning is a difficult one
in a cheeky way i would say if you went
to the library of congress and you
learned everything there was to know in
the universe and you had some amazing
insight and then you got hit by a bus
it wouldn't be all that useful that you
learned all that so for me
trying to find another term that has
meaning and so i've
i've come to this term of machine
intelligence of
putting machine learning into practice
right i think it's easy
uh in sort of the on the theoretical
side
and maybe with a computer science lens
as you're thinking about a new machine
learning algorithm
to think about classifying irises you
know with your new great algorithm
but but the data that we actually get in
the real world
uh is noisy and it's subversive and it's
fuzzy and we don't really have a great
answer and
the color of a pedal of an iris is not
purple plus or minus red
the kinds of data we actually get in the
real world has noise
and sometimes it's missing and it's it's
dirty
and so putting the results of machine
learning into practice
i haven't seen much of that uh in in
academia
um i've we see it obviously a lot uh in
industry where they've been able to
recognize the importance of doing great
machine learning that works in practice
because if they got it wrong they're
sort of real resource implications
does a botanist really care whether
we've got a great classifier
of different types of irises i don't
know have any
anyone actually asked the botanist do
you care about that
what's important is that we need to
figure out ways to get machine learning
working
for uh the types of science that are
collecting
lots and lots of data asking these um
very complex questions
on that on that data and i think it's
only really just uh beginning
so i wanted to come back at the end here
to this
picture that i showed you at the
beginning it's very very dark
of the computers in the room at harvard
and not
point out um the uh the light curve
but actually point out this person in
the foreground here her name is
henrietta swan levitt
and she was the discoverer of the period
luminosity relation of cepheid stars
and that discovery that she made in this
room um
around the same time when this picture
was taken was because she decided she
wasn't all that interested in binary
stars and she
started thinking about pulsating stars
the work that she did
became the basis for edwin hubble's
first measurement of the expansion of
the universe it's the genesis
of modern cosmology and
so what i end with is a question that i
don't have the answer to
is even though we're using machine
learning to really automate the whole
astrophysics stack and remove people
from the loop
can machines be taught to ask the
questions that we haven't
or or we can't will machine intelligence
ever replace the
eureka moments by people and will the
entire astrophysics stack
not just from the data collection um but
to the initial classification
but to the real breakthroughs will that
ever be able to be
um truly automated so um i'll end
uh with just a couple of sort of
concluding statements
the modern astrophysics stack is
obviously drawing very deeply from
contemporary
computer science theory it's great
because these frameworks exist
uh it's not so great because it means we
it's a massive educational challenge
now it means i have to teach my students
not just about
the mundane things like exploding stars
but now i need to teach them about tool
kits that perhaps i don't even know
about
um but it's pretty clear in the context
of the data deluge for astronomers
that there is a huge demand for the
abstraction of the traditional roles of
people
from the from the ordinary scientific
process that we've been
used to um and yet despite all that
i think it's pretty clear that there
remains a very important role for for
people and i don't want to give that up
so with that um i'll end the talk and uh
and say thank you
well thanks for a beautiful talk let's
have a few questions
slide
yes good okay i can do that yep
yeah so the question is what are people
actually doing with uh with this
with this sort of emergent network um i
think they actually are
looking at um asteroids and using these
uh networks
to to follow up um interesting
near-earth asteroids that could be um
pretty dangerous
that is actually happening what's great
though is that if you have this network
they don't all have to be doing
the same thing at the same time maybe
they spend 10 minutes of their night
doing this
maybe one telescope is more interested
in doing it than another telescope
we've tried to figure it again because
this is all about resource maximization
uh we've tried to think about how you
actually have telescopes from different
groups that have
sort of different needs um sort of
sharing data with each other when
perhaps they've never even collaborated
with each other so we've invented
sort of a currency uh for these
telescopes
called starbucks um hopefully we won't
get sued but um
you know that that again makes it very
easy once once there is that currency
and people
believe in that currency um to actually
do the best with the resources that you
have
uh the classification scheme uh you
showed us
uh has it been frozen for ages or it
started
developing and do you expect during your
lifetime to add another
another branch yeah so the question was
about the
classification scheme that sort of rats
nest of uh
of taxonomy um it it has to change
because first of all we're making new
discoveries and we usually try to slot a
new object
into one of the existing uh uh classes
and eventually it becomes pretty clear
that it just doesn't belong there
anymore and
and it will wind up branching out there
are new classes of variable stars found
every every say a couple of years
and usually it happens now with the very
sort of subtle changes of light curves
because the really sort of explosive
events have been announcing themselves
for 300 years and people have been
following them up and trying to
understand them so yes i i think that
classification taxonomy will change and
one of the things that i think might be
interesting
is to take um you know sort of machine
learning concepts
and figure out actual distances between
all of these different objects
and see whether there's any sort of um
you know phylogenetic tree that winds up
emerging out of it
or concepts of species of species
you folks are trying very hard to use
computer science but don't you also want
to
recruit from computer science are there
so this is a this is a excellent
question um
and i'm glad to be able to address that
a bit uh
the question was about um you know
whether we
actually want to recruit from computer
science and and bring people in to
essentially help us out
uh that would be great um but i think
what's more exciting about this
conversation that
astronomers are having with computer
scientists is that and i
i hope you all see this is that we're
presenting to you uh
data sets and types of questions that
perhaps there is not yet
a well-established theory to to answer
and to address
and so i see this much more as a a
collaborative
uh kind of of communication rather than
one where we're basically just sort of
drawing on on uh on people in in a sort
of more rote way
um i i think what we've done in the
center for time domain informatics
uh with other faculty in the computer
science
department and and in stats is produce
for them a set of
really important science questions that
we would love to be able to answer if
only they could develop the theory and
the formal mechanisms
for us to do that with enough grounding
that we believe we're on to
we're on to something
okay
yeah so the question is if you're you
know getting gaining confidence
that you've got this awesome pipeline
that doesn't require graduate students
anymore
in the real-time loop how do you gain
confidence that you're not missing
something
really important something you hadn't
thought about
i don't know the answer to that i mean
one one could try to sort of throw
um dummy events into the data stream and
hope that you actually wind up catching
those
um and make but but then again if you're
throwing a dummy event in
it's still within the realm of the uh
you know the known unknowns
if something is truly different than
anything we've ever thought about
it's going to be pretty hard to
guarantee that you're never you're never
going to miss things like that
and that in some sense maybe where the
frontier gets pushed to
is um you know the next generation of
people doing
uh machine learning and automating
workflows have to figure out ways to
uncover the unknown unknowns in in a
more systematic way it's a good question
you